thank you
I have a lot of pride to be here for a
special reason
because of a special man his name is
Henry Fonda
as an actor he is the definition of
dedication and professionalism something
we can all be proud of an example to us
all Henry Fonda loves to act and as the
true portrait of the working actor for
the past 46 years in an 86 film so far
his presence has reflected the special
nature of the American character the
best of what we like to think we are his
ability and his integrity as an actor
has shown us the face of our country in
a variety of different ways from Abe
Lincoln to Tom Joad Wyatt Earp to mr.
Roberts and each time we come away
knowing a little bit more about
ourselves and feeling a little better
for it
Andrey Fonda's performances always carry
a special dignity that shows us that
there is no such thing as a small or
unimportant person
Henry you have honored us over the years
with your work and it pleases us here
tonight to be able to honor you with our
appreciation and this special Oscar
thank you Robert thank you when I
realized and I really have to remind
myself that I've been working in films
for 46 years I feel I'm a very very
lucky man
not just because I survived but because
over the years I've had the opportunity
to work with some of the best producers
best directors writers best actors in
motion pictures it's been a very
rewarding 46 years for me and this has
got to be the climax I'm very proud and
very grateful to the governors of the
Academy thank you very much